michel c'est pas une bonne idée michel
est ce que tu travailles beaucoup des
émissions beaucoup c'est vrai pourquoi
ouais bah tout le temps quand vraiment
genre pour leur rendez vous doux travail
combien de toute la semaine j'ai
travaillé 50 ans en gros ouais bon
arriver à ce résultat là bas c'est bon
c'est mettre 60 ans l'année prochaine
mais si un jour tu travailles tu
travailles toute une tout le temps
l'histoire d'abord je fais mon sport le
matin je te regarde je regarde toutes
les chaînes ont elles regardent toutes
les séries je regarde tous les films
dont je parle les pièces de théâtre j'y
vais les voir en matinée parce que mon
cardio matane me couchais tard les notes
je vois que tout je vois tout passe et
où vous êtes a interviewé un acteur j'ai
pas vu son fils n'ont plus eu un
problème
inverse
je n'arrive vraiment une exacte je
n'arrive pas à trouver quand je les ai
vus c'est vrai je suis bien meilleur
voilà la donne et des deux prochaines
émissions que je fais je reçois de dany
boon et enid renault pour un film
bouleversant
ensuite je fais un spécial bovine avec
son fils pour n'a jamais vu j'ai re
visionner plein plein de choses je
voudrais rencontrer le fils de bourvil
qui est un brillant universitaire qui
n'a jamais parlé de son père la
télévision et puis je prends beaucoup d'
avance je travaille tout le temps parce
que c'est ma passion c'est c'est en
rééducation et au fond de mon lit à
l'hôpital que j'ai écrit dans ce
spectacle oui oui
c'est bon on vraiment les émissions
mêmes et
toi qui bosse comme un fou la passion
fatigue port non non mais non de
travailler c'est pas bien le panier un
petit conseil il m'a dit à genève où un
jour charles qui était mauvaise en
provence soyez aussi inquiet quand ça
marche exactement marche pas donc ça m'a
moi je suis toujours inquiet je suis
toujours inquiet ah bon c'est un cui a
bien sûr est ce que tu vois quand je te
va commencer l'émission dès aujourd'hui
les scores qu'on a fait hier soir je
vais attendre venir ce soit dépourvu que
je bosse pas exactement c'est vrai
exactement comment les deux tours bat
rien qui soit ça ne dit pas ça non il
faut tendre facilement d'entraînement
quand j'ai pris la succession de jacques
martin j'ai mis un an benji s'en
souvient on en a mais les gens venaient
aux cieux gabriel réclament l école des
fans n'auront à sion la première année
plus belle la vie hein
noir ils ont laissé 18 ans donc il faut
être patient est certain et c'est la
grande vertu du service public on peut
attendre le temps ça se passe bien dans
le service public oui effectivement tout
cadeau qu'on m'a fait c'est qui et qui
alors que c'est un cadeau que tu as fait
le service public que madame ma fille
delphine ernotte finances en charge des
jeunes tous les deux 7 ans et kamel
présidente ayez à ma faim cadeau cela
personne ne connaît et regarde c'est un
scoop le premier micro des jeux
olympiques de 2020
[Applaudissements]
diffuseur officiel francetv fr 2 c'est
le service public qui va diffuser les
jeux rapides 2024 et moi c'est très
émouvant pour moi parce qu'ils m'ont
demandé de faire partie je sais pas ce
qu'on va faire de fait partie de
l'équipe avec lui et moi je suis le seul
rescapé ne rit pas des jeux olympiques
de tokyo 64 et safa 60 ans de carrière
donc c'est très émouvant
[Applaudissements]
c'est trop gros cas qui réalise la
même regarder c'est la première fois que
vous voyez aucun voile à france tv sport
diffusé ce qui va me dire là on a même
les images de tous en 64 c'est vrai
ouais tu crois quoi ils bossent les
équipes en
lisant le président de la fédération des
handicapés physiques de france les
représentants français ont obtenu trois
médailles à tokyo je pense que vous êtes
satisfait du résultat eh bien je suis
très satisfait
en faveur de tokyo où elle avait obtenu
à vous tous seuls quatre médailles d'or
vous êtes vraiment le ton sans lenteur
de cette équipe ouais enfin trois
médailles d'or et trois médailles d'or
et une d'argent ouais on dit 500
danseurs l'envers quoi mais ça a
vraiment été dur
[Applaudissements]
mais civile je réalise quand j'ai vu la
une de match ont toujours comment tu
veux que je réalise que j'ai quatre fois
vingt ans un médecin et c'est joli ça tu
pense pas à ça bah si tu y penses ah oui
quand je prends ma bouillie le soin
voiture rouge tu trouves laquelle on le
sentait une bonne question là tu vois je
vais te quitter tout à l'heure ouais
puisque puisque tout à l'heure tu vas
avoir un sujet qui n'a plus rien à voir
bien tu vas recevoir des élèves qui
appartiennent à jc wii u ce drame je
voulais servant les saluer parce que moi
je suis de basse normandie et le lycée
malherbe canet c'est un peu mon enfance
je suis un supporter des frais mais la
fia mais il y en a le drame qui a eu
dans ce lycée bien ça m'a beaucoup
touché parce que j'ai grandi là mais je
ferme la porte aux dépens de la question
a touché que je pars d'ici oui je vais
regarder sur canal j'ai vu hervé mathoux
ouais le match du psg qui joue à haïfa
exactement voilà tout en travaillant tu
vas travailler
mes projets je suis sur scène dans
quinze jours tu dois prendre le tas
prétexte mais je le connais montée j'ai
joué 21 mai mais je
les compte ces risques
l'adolescence quand il se met à dos et
il bosse beaucoup ça m'a regardé comme
les paresseux non mais je rêve sur les
émissions et écrites ou l'autre
ils prenaient note est ou non tu sais
pourquoi je travaille beaucoup plus que
les autres tu sais pourquoi parce que
jamais utilisé ni prompteur nasa voilà
donc j'ai intérêt à voir
je n'ai jamais pu utiliser une
oreillette ni panthers 1 parce que quand
j'étais l'assistant titre on dire la
chanteuse réparer mon minitel suis tout
seul à la tranquillité tout seul